there's something so special about the
food you grew up eating
it's something we take for granted in
its simplicity and frequency
another thing we rush past only to stop
and think about it years down the road
when her souls yearn for it out of the
blue on a sunny thursday afternoon
a lot of people call it soul food
i call it
i think all of us have a food that so
deeply touches the inner parts of her
soul and nourishes not just our bodies
but everything else too
it replenishes us with exactly what we
were missing and pushes some sort of
reset button back to her centered state
granted
our center and reset mode are always
changing because we as humans are
writing the constant flow of change a
lot of us move through this either by
evolving making ourselves into shinier
newer versions of ourselves or by
reflecting peeling the layers back and
finding out who we really are at our
core and in the midst of all this life
is always throwing new things our way to
deal with maybe it's a rejection from a
school
a job or a crush or it's a new
opportunity in a new city
at a new job with a new friend sometimes
life throws unimaginably difficult
challenges and other times it throws us
exactly what we didn't know we needed
but i think there's something about soul
food that brings us right back to where
we feel like we're supposed to be
i feel like that with onigiri like when
chihiro eats that onigiri that haku
gives her and bawls her eyes out i feel
that in my soul
maybe it just brings me back to the
onigiri that my mom made with her warm
soft hands for us whenever we needed a
snack or the gigantic single onigiri
that my dad would make for us to bring
to lunch that often lacked a feeling but
never lacked in care and love
it was one of the few things i felt okay
bringing to school for lunch in a sea of
lunchables
my one symbol and reminder that would
help keep me in touch with myself
throughout my younger years
omg still plays a significant role in my
life and has meant different things to
me at different times
sometimes it's the exact on-the-go snack
i need for a busy day and other days
it's the only thing i want after coming
back from a trip
it's amazing that something so simple
and humble
can have such significance
if we give it
onigiri is a really simple dish
rice
salt
a filling or hurikake and usually a nori
to wrap it all up there's really only
one way that people make it but for
whatever reason every single onigiri is
different depending on who's making it
realistically it's probably the
combination of the shape and warmth of
their hands that mold it together the
amount of salt they use and of course
their filling choice and the way that
it's filled but i think it's because
each onigiri includes the love
care and life of who's making it there's
a piece of their soul in there
and no two ongigiri are the same because
no two people are the same
eating it feels like it taps me into the
deepest parts of my soul granted it
doesn't always give me answers but it
completely centers me and gives me
mental clarity
and i think that's what's so grounding
about onigiri for me
[Music]
thank you for watching this video and
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video going to therapy is one of
the best things that i've done for
myself in my adult life it's really
helped me to understand my mind and
mental health a lot better so i highly
recommend it if there's something
interfering with your happiness or it's
preventing you from achieving your goals
then better betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating within 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise in betterhelp's 15 000 plus
counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas and the
service itself is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor where you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today so visit
betterhelp.com
myuco that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional there's a special offer
just to my subscribers where you can get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
myuco
[Music]
[Music]
you